you mentioned uganda yeah yeah joseph
coney the ugandan warlord um seeing here
he kidnapped
591 children in three years between two
totally they must have kidnapped
i had
they probably kidnapped for at least a
short time like a few hours to a day
more than 50 000 kids
as a terror tactic
a little bit i mean um you know most of
those people they just let go after they
carried goods they'd held on to they
tried to hold on to thousands the short
story listen if you're not popular if
you're running an arm movement and you
need troops
um
you can i and nobody wants to fight for
you you can either give up or you can
have a small clandestine terror
organization that tries to a different
set of tactics but if you want a
conventional army and you don't want to
give up then you have to conscript
and if you want to conscript and you
don't
you know here we can script and then we
say if you run away we'll shoot you and
we control the whole territory so
we'll we that's a credible promise
um
if you're a small insurgency
organization people can run away and
then you can't promise to shoot them
very easily because you don't control
all the territory and so what these
movements do is they try to brainwash
you
and i think what they figured out after
years of abducting children you know you
talk about evil
um
they figured out that you know we have
to
maybe like i don't know but say like
maybe one in a hundred will like buy the
rhetoric so we just have to
conscript or abduct large number of kids
and then some small number of them will
not run away
and those will be our committed cadres
and those people can become commanders
and because they'll buy the propaganda
and they'll buy the messianic messages
but but because most people wise up we
have especially as they get older we
just have to abduct vast numbers of kids
in order to have a committed cadre and
so
so it has the other benefit of sort of
being terrifying for the population and
being a weapon in itself
but i think for them was just primarily
a way to solve
a recruitment problem
uh when you're
a totally
uh like
hopeless and
uh ideologically empty rebel movement so
in some sense it's
it's yeah so it that that's maybe the
short story was a real tragedy i heard
one interview of a dictator
uh where the journalist was basically
telling them like how could you be doing
this
uh basically calling out all the
atrocities the person is committing
and the dictator was kind of laughing it
off and walked away yeah and like he cut
off the interview that feel like a very
unproductive thing to be doing
you're basically stating the thing that
everyone knows to his face maybe that's
pleasant to somebody
uh but that feels unproductive
it feels like the goal should be some
level of understanding yeah
he's been super elusive
yeah i mean why he's fought this
i don't know
you know it's not a great example of
that's an you know what the way i look
at that situation
is
it's a little bit particular the way
uganda works but um
most of the political leadership
for most of its post-independence
history came from the north of the
country
that was like the power base
and and there was dictatorial and they
were so you've heard of like people like
eating mean but people heard of like
milton a boat day and all these people
were all from the north
uh
and then you get the current president
who came to power in 1986 so he's been
around a long time he's gonna be 70 he
um
he was from the south
and his he was fighting and he was
fighting against these dictators and he
was fighting for a freer and better
uganda and in many ways i mean he's he's
still a dictator himself but he did
create a freer and better uganda
so he's better than these
he's a thug but he was better than thugs
before him
um and he came to power and he was like
and and these
some of the northerners were like we
want to keep up the fight
and he was like you know what you guys
i'm gonna i'm strong enough to continue
the north you guys go you want have you
want to have a crazy insurgency up there
and some kook
believes he's like
uh speaking
you know through the holy spirit's
you know speaking through him and he's
going to totally disrupt the north
i i don't care that's great you guys
just
fester and fight
and
that's going to totally destabilize this
power this traditional power base and
then that's just going to help me
consolidate control so he was an
autocrat he was an unchecked leader who
allowed a lunatic
to run around
and uh cause mayhem because it was in
his political interest to do so
uh and
there's no puzzle
it's it's it's in some ways it's that
simple and kind of tragic
there's little to understand
yeah it took me a lot well you know what
it's not so easy in the middle of it
i didn't understand that i don't think a
lot of people did and and i'm not i
think i could persuade most people who
study or work there now to like see it
that way i think people that would make
sense to people but it didn't make sense
in the moment you know in the moment
this is happening it's terrible and you
kind of you know you don't realize how
avoidable it was that basically it was
the absence of effective police actions
that kept the lunatic from being
contained
um
and and that lunatic would never you
know he's not it's not that skillful of
our movement right they could have it
could have been shut down and that there
was just never any political will to
shut it down the opposite that's what i
meant like that unchecked leader not
only do you not bear the cost but you
might have a private incentive as an
autocrat to like see that violence
happen and in this case it was it was
just keeping a troublesome part of the
country busy
you